Okay.
Uh,
at the end last time we were looking at how you could possibly know the heat of
atomization of graphite,
how much energy it takes to put a carbon atom into the gas phase from graphite.
Why would you want to know that?
Why is that a key value for what purpose?
If you want to be able to know whether you can add together bonds and get the
energy of a molecule,
that means you start with separated Adams
and you then see how much energy is given off when those come together to give a
particular molecule to make a whole bunch of bonds.
Right now you can measure that the energy of a molecule with respect to CO2
quite easily.
How do you do that?
Burn it and you can measure the co two relative to graphite.
How do you know the energy of a carbon in the energy of co two relative to the
energy of graphite plus oxygen
burn graphite.
Okay,
but the last thing you need is the energy of graphite relative to the Adam.
And if you then knew that,
then you could complete this scheme and know just by burning things,
whether you can add together bond energies to get the energy of a molecule.
Okay,
so how do you get the energy from graphite to an atom?
One way is spectroscopy,
and we talked about that last time,
that if you,
if you see what the minimum amount of energy you can put into co two and have it
break into two Adams,
that gives you the energy of the two atoms relative to CO2.
Pardon me,
relative to see,
oh,
I should be saying right.
And then you burn CEO and get it relative to co two and then you have everything
you need.
Okay.
Except the people who were very smart,
Nobel prize winners and so on,
deferred on interpreting this because some of them thought that when you break
CO2 into Adams with the light,
the atom you get is not the lowest energy state of the atom,
but a higher energy state of the atom.
So some of the energy you're putting in is going into making an excited Adam.
And the true energy of forming the minimum energy carbon atom from graphite is
lower than what you do.
Spectroscopically.
So the spectroscopic value is very precise.
You can measure the position,
the color of the light very accurately,
but they didn't know what it corresponded to.
So they needed a different way to know what the energy of the carbon atom was
relative to graphite.
Now,
uh,
professor Sharpless said,
you know,
he,
he talked about increasing dimension of carbon.
Start with an Adam,
go to a line,
Polyacetal lead,
and then do a bunch of double bonds.
And finally to a saturated hydrocarbon.
He said that carbon atoms are very hard to come by.
You need a really,
really low vacuum to get it right.
That is the equilibrium constant for carbon atoms coming together to form bonds
is very,
very favorable,
right?
So it's hard to get Adam's,
so how are you ever going to get Adam's?
Well,
let's think about that problem here.
So we know that the equilibrium constant is at room temperature is 10 to the
minus three fourths,
Delta e.
So you could measure k then you know Delta e.
So,
but if,
if the equilibrium you're trying to measure is between graphite and carbon atoms
and the energy to take a carbon atom out of graphite is 170 kilocalories per
mole than the equilibrium constant is 10 to the minus 127 right?
And that means since there are only something of the order of 10 to the 80 atoms
in the universe,
there would not be at room temperature,
a single carbon atom at equilibrium with,
with graphite,
if everything in the universe was graphite,
right?
So it's not a very favorable equilibrium constant.
What could you do about it if you wanted to measure the equilibrium constant and
in that way,
get the energy difference.
Any knobs you can twist Lucas temperature,
you can increase the temperature,
right?
Because it's Delta e over k t and remember we're talking about room temperature.
So if we met much higher than room temperature,
then the exponent gets much smaller.
So,
suppose we went to 10 times room temperature to 3000 Kelvin,
right?
Then it would be instead of three fourths,
it would be three fortieths cause the denominator would be 10 times bigger.
And now it would be one in 10 to the 13th would be an Adam.
And now that's a substantial number.
If you're talking about Avogadro's number.
So if you had something really,
really sensitive to measure Adams,
you might be able to able to measure the Adams at equilibrium,
but you have to establish equilibrium.
It's something of the order of 3000 degrees,
or at least really,
really hot,
right?
So you could write the equilibrium constant that the concentration of Adam's
over the concentration of graphite in this way that he has to do that is the
heat of formation.
Adam's relative to graphite right now,
of course,
exactly what one means by the concentration of graphite,
uh,
needs to be,
you scratch your head a little bit about that,
right?
But you don't actually need to know it because if you could measure the pressure
of the c Adams at equilibrium with graphite at very high temperature,
call that the pressure of carbon,
right?
That is some constant and that constant will include whatever this concentration
of graphite should be so be so multiply both sides by that concentration of
graphite,
right?
So we get some constant on the right and then that heat a formation in the
exponent that we want to find.
So that means we could,
right,
if we took the log of both sides,
you have the log of the pressure of carbon atoms is log of whatever be is that
some constant minus this other term?
And what that means is that if you that that minus the heat of formation to the
carbon atom divided by r is the slope of a plot of the pressure of carbon atoms
versus one over t is everyone see that in that equation?
That equation says that there's an intercept which is the log of B and the slope
which is minus Delta h formation of carbon divided by r.
If you plot against one over t everybody with me on that,
not if you see it,
okay?
So all you need to do is plot the log of the pressure of carbon atoms,
which will be very low versus one over t at very high temperature,
right?
Or the order of 3000 Kelvin.
So that's not easy to do,
but it was done in 1955 by Chubb,
Fka and Ingram.
And this is the,
the,
uh,
a sketch of their,
of their instrument.
And I'll go show you how they did it first,
there's a graphite cylinder,
okay?
And around it is a can made out of tantalum.
Now,
why tantalum?
Because that's about the highest melting thing you can get.
It's the highest melting metal.
So 3000,
293 Kelvin as it's melting point.
So you could really hate the heck out of this thing.
Okay?
And now you surround that with wires and those wires are made of tungsten
because that's very high belting too.
And so you connect,
why are you,
you can you connect a electricity to the,
to those,
to the tungsten.
And also to the tantalum.
So electrons boil off the tungsten and bombard the tantalum.
And when the electrons heat it,
they hit it,
they heat it up.
So you can heat the heck out of this tantalum can by bombarding it with
electrons.
And that of course heats the graphite that's inside now.
So inside there's going to be a gas of carbon in equilibrium with the graphite.
Now it won't just be Seattle's,
there'll also be t c two c three c 60 70 and so on,
but lots of different forms of carbon as a guest.
So you can't just measure the pressure in there.
And indeed it would be tough to measure the pressure inside at 3000 degrees,
but you at least have these things.
They're at equilibrium.
Now what he,
what they did,
Chuck Good Ingram was the drill,
a tiny hole in the top of this thing.
And that will allow a little bit of the gas to escape.
Not so much that you destroy the equilibrium inside,
just a really slow leak,
right?
So now if you could measure the amount of these different carbon species leaking
out,
you could know what the pressure of them was inside the can.
Okay,
now,
so there's a beam of carbon species coming out.
Gaseous carbon species.
This is all at very,
very high vacuum,
right?
And then up there,
an electron beam comes across and hits these carbon things and knocks electrons
out of them,
and that converts them into c Plus C one c two c three c 60 plus.
Okay,
so you have a beam coming out of these charged carbon species.
Now why do you want them to be charged for two reasons?
One,
so you can detect them because you can detect it when charge hits a plate.
And the other one is so you can deflect the beams with a magnetic field,
right?
So these various carbon species come out and they go into a magnetic field,
which puts a lateral force on them and causes them to bend.
And of course the lighter they are,
the easier they are to bend.
If they all have the same charge.
So you're going to get curved trajectories.
C three plus c two plus c one plus will be the most bent.
And now if you put a detector at these different positions,
you can see how much c one,
how much CPU,
how much c three there were,
there was.
Okay,
so that's how you're going to do it.
But this machine has to be pretty special because you're heating it.
So Hi Lucas electrons.
It can knock off two,
but then you get it at a very different position.
You can tell these things.
This thing is called mass spectroscopy,
but it knocks off one much more often than it knocks off two or three.
Kind of the same problems we had with the other thing.
The other thing,
I can't remember what we couldn't measure the other one because it was a higher
energy state.
Might it be an excited state yet?
No,
because it's an equilibrium.
The excited state would be much,
much less at equilibrium because it's higher in energy.
Okay,
good.
Good point though.
Good.
You thought about that now.
So you have to put shielding around this stuff so it doesn't melt everything.
So you use tantalum,
which is high melting and eh,
and a series of can inside a can like Russian dolls,
right?
So the,
the inside,
inside most one is very,
very hot than a little less hot,
a little less hot.
Okay.
So you shield it and now you need to know the temperature inside.
And you do it by drilling a tiny hole through those shields.
So you can have what's called an optical pyrometer.
That's just something that looks at the color of something that's really hot and
something that's hot gives our,
even something that's cold gives off black body radiation.
And the color has to do with the,
uh,
with the temperature.
You know,
there's red heat,
yt,
blue heat and so on.
So by measuring the color,
you can see what the temperature was inside and that window that the light comes
through has to be made of courts,
not Pyrex glass.
You know,
why?
Cause Pyrex glass would melt even at that distance,
right?
So that you use,
uh,
court's glass.
Okay?
So that's what you do.
And here's a graph of the pressure of these various species measured with that
mass spectrometer at different temperatures measured as one over the temperature
here.
So it goes from 2150 Kelvin to 24 50 Kelvin and the pressure increases and it's
plotted as the log of the intensity of the signal.
That is the pressure times temperature because the pressure has to be corrected
for temperature.
Because if you have the same number of things giving the pressure but they're
hotter,
there'll be pressing harder on things.
There'll be.
So you have,
it's the,
it's the intensity of the signal times the temperature that you plot there.
And from the slope you can see up there at the top that foresee one you get the
slope says it's a 171 kilocalories per mole QED.
Right now,
you know,
which was the right one measured by spectroscopy.
It was the one that said 171 so this experiment actually measuring the
equilibrium between carbon atoms and graphite by a really a Gargantuan kind of
experiment is what settled the question finally.
So that when you look at the appendix of this book,
striped,
wiser,
half Cochon costs hour,
you find that there are heats of formation for Adams and radicals measured by
spectroscopy and things like this.
And there you see carbon 170.9 and that was done by professor Chupp go who was
in this department and who used to come and tell people how he did this
experiment.
But as you can see,
he passed away in 2007 so thanks to Professor Chupp Cook.
And the Nice thing is,
once that's done,
it's done.
Now you know it and you just plug it in when you burn your stuff and want to
know what its energy as you could get it relative to carbon atoms in the gas
phase.
Okay.
Now how good are these spectroscopic experiments?
Well,
this is a neat thing.
The heat of atomization of methane measured in the ways we've just been talking
about is 397.5 kilocalories per mole.
Now that is co comes from Ma meeting a carbon atom with four hydrogen atoms.
That is 397.5 right?
So we know what the average bond energy there for such bonds,
so each was worth 99.4 kilocalories per mole.
So about a hundred kilocalories per mole for a ch bond.
That's convenient to remember,
okay,
but that's not how much it costs to take a single hydrogen atom away from
methane taking a single hydrogen atom away from methane and the so called bond
dissociation energy,
which is the actual experimental energy it takes to do some particular process.
Everage bond energy is just an average,
but the individual ones are not the same.
Taking a hydrogen away from methane is 104 point 99 plus or minus 0.03
kilocalories per mole close,
but not the same thing.
And then you have ch three if you take another second h off that it's 110.4 the
next one is 101.3 and the final one taking Hoa from C is only 80.9 right now.
These are,
these are done by spectroscopy and Barney Ellison may come talk to us in the
spring.
He is often traveling through and talks about how he measured these things.
But those are done by spectroscopy.
But the neat thing about it is if you add all those four numbers together,
so pardon me,
I was going to say no individual bond equals the average,
right?
But if you add them together,
you get 397.5 which is precisely the average.
So these are very good experiments.
So we know through heroic a spectroscopy and these,
this work of chuck good and Ingram,
we know what these energies are.
Bond Energies and Bond Association,
dissociation energies.
So here our average bond energies in a table that you have at the end of this
organic chemistry text,
and it says a carbon hydrogen bond is 99 and now you see where we get that.
Uh,
and you see that the carbon,
uh,
carbon bond is 83,
but the second carbon carbon bond and the double bond is only 63,
right?
Why is it weaker?
Why is the second bond of a carbon carbon double bond weaker?
Then the first,
pardon me,
Devon,
what do you say?
Yeah,
you have bad overlap between the Pi electrons.
In fact,
the first,
the single bond,
the a double bond is probably stronger than a normal single bond.
Can anybody see why that would be?
Scott Morris character better overlap?
Sp squared,
sp squared.
So the second one is probably more than 20 kilocalories weaker than the single
one.
But at any rate,
it's 146 for that you add up to get a double bond and 200 for a triple bond,
which means the third bond is worth only 54 kilocalories per mole.
Okay?
Uh,
and in c double Bondo,
it's uh,
it's about the same as,
as cc.
So CEO is 86.
Uh,
but the double bond notice is different in this case.
Now the second bond is stronger than the first.
So the carbon eel group is an especially stable group.
Okay.
So you have the question,
can you sum up these average bond energies and get useful heats of atomization?
So can you look at a structure and say how stable it's going to be?
Okay,
so let's try it.
So here's heats of atomization by additives,
city of average bond energies.
So we have these average bond energies from the table.
A CC single bond is 83 is c h is 99 c double bond c is 1406806111 and so on.
And we're going to set them all up to give the heat of at and compare it with
the actual heat of atomization.
Okay,
so for ethene there,
there are four ch bonds.
There's one CC double bond,
add them up,
and you get 542 the actual heat of atomization is 537.7 so there's,
there's an error of 4.3 kilocalories per mole,
which is less than 1% that's pretty good.
But on the other hand,
ethene probably entered in to determining these average bond energies,
right?
So it's not a hundred percent fair.
Okay.
How about cyclohexane?
Now we have six carbon carbon's single bonds and 12 carbon hydrogen single
bonds,
1686 versus 1680 0.1 and error of only 5.9 less than half a percent error.
So pretty good by adding up bond cyclohexanone [inaudible] remember we had quite
a bit of trouble with these partly oxidized things before when we were trying to
just do it on the basis of the elements.
But if you add bonds together,
you get within 0.3% of the right value.
Or if you do glucose,
which has a lots of oxygens in it,
then you get a within again,
less than 1% 0.7% of the right value.
So this is pretty darn good.
Very impressive.
Very small errors to predict these.
But the question is,
is it useful?
How accurate does it have to be to be useful?
So why do,
why do you need to know the values?
Because you want to know equilibrium constants.
You want to know which direction a reaction will go,
for example.
Okay,
so we know that the,
if we want to calculate a,
an equilibrium constant,
we can do it at room temperature with this three fourths drink.
So the calculated equilibrium constant is whatever we're calculating here for
energy between two things,
we have two things.
Calculate the energy of these,
the energy of these.
Compare to the energies and that'll give us the equilibrium constant according
to this formula.
But notice I'm doing it on the basis of calculation now.
Uh,
so that's whatever the calculated energy is,
whatever the true energy would be.
But there's also some error in there.
Okay.
But if you add two exponent,
that's the same as multiplying two things together.
So the calculated equilibrium constant is the true equilibrium constant.
That's the first part.
The part that has with Delta h true times,
the part that has this exponent,
right?
Three fourths of that Delta h error.
So if you want the error to be small,
that factor to be small than Delta h error has to be small,
small,
not on a percentage basis,
but absolutely it has to be small that that error,
not the percentage error determines this error factor.
Right?
So to keep the error less than a factor of 10 in the equilibrium constant,
you need to know that equilibrium constants within 1.3 kilocalories per mole.
So that three fourths of it will be one.
And that would mean you'd be within a factor of 10.
Everybody with me on this.
So you need to do even better than this.
You can't use the average bond energies and get something that's very useful
because if you're off by 16 down here in the case of sugar,
that beans,
you're off by a factor of 10 to the 12th in predicting the equilibrium constant,
which wouldn't be acceptable probably.
Okay.
Uh,
so let's try it with the equilibrium between a ketone and the so called Enal,
which is an isomer of a ketone in which a hydrogen has been taken from the
methyl group on the right and put on the oxygen and a double bond moved.
Okay,
so that's a very important equilibrium that will encounter when we talk about
the chemistry of ketones.
Let's see what the equilibrium constant.
Should there be more ketone or more enal?
You have a guest right off the out at the outset of which one would be more
stable.
I would guess the key tone because what I just told you that the COO double bond
is remarkably stable.
Right?
And the other case you have a CC double bond.
Okay.
Let's see.
Now we could add together all the bonds,
but most of them are the most bonds are the same between the starting material
and product.
We only need to compare the ones that change.
Okay,
so we've highlighted in red the bonds that change between the two forms,
the two isomers
cause we're interested in the difference in energy between these two to get the
equilibrium constant.
Okay,
so these are the numbers I took from the table that you see on the top left
there 179 for CEO,
double bond and so on.
Uh,
and I saw them up and that's 361 for those bonds and the new set of bonds in the
eternal,
some to 343 so the ketone indeed is more stable.
It appears by 18 kilocalories per mole.
So 18 kilocalories per mole means that you have a factor of 10 to the 13th.
The equilibrium constant is tend to the 13.5.
So it should lie for practical purposes entirely in the direction of the ketone.
However,
if you do it experimentally,
you find that the equilibrium constant is only 10 to the seventh not 10 to the
14th right?
So the true energy difference is 9.3 kilocalories,
not the 18 that we got by adding bonds together.
Right?
So that means we're going to have to deal with,
uh,
addressing why the eternal is too stable.
It's nine kilocalories per mole to stable compared to our predictions on the
basis of adding bonds together.
Now,
why?
Well,
one thing is that we,
that those bonds that we canceled to ch bonds that didn't change,
in fact did change between the starting material and the product.
Why could I say that?
They did change and both cases on both sides,
they're single carbon carbon.
It's carbon hydrogen bonds.
How can I say they change Angela,
right?
They're changing hybridization actually.
Yeah.
There go from sp three to SB two on the carbon as you go across and the SP twos
on the right,
it should be more stable.
Okay.
So the SB two h should be stronger,
so that's good.
The,
so these things that I was saying canceled,
do not actually cancel if we take hybridization into account.
So that's one factor.
And there's another,
uh,
as well,
which as you have that unshared pair of on the top right here on the oxygen is
adjacent to a double bond.
That means that this high homo can be stabilized by the Pi star low Lumo.
We'll overlap that isn't the possibility here where the unshared pairs on the
oxygen did not overlap with the Pi.
Uh,
Pi Star orbital.
so you get in trouble like killer Homo Lumo mixing in the eternal that you don't
get in the ketone,
which will help stabilize the enal.
With that,
we could draw that resonance structure.
So those two things together make up that nine kilocalories error,
or at least we can think they contribute to it at least.
So constitutional energy,
what we would get by adding bonds together,
uh,
has to be corrected for various effects.
We,
we'll call them such as resonance.
That's what we just looked at.
Like this homo Lumo thing such as hybridization changes or such as strain as in
the case of axial methyl cyclohexane that we looked at.
So there are lots of lots of these corrections that you have to apply to this
model where you add together,
uh,
bond energies in order to predict the energies of a particular molecule.
But for many cases,
now you can do a pretty good job of predicting these things and actually not do
so bad at predicting,
uh,
relative energies of isomers and therefore equilibrium constants.
And these,
the effects of course are a polite name for error,
right?
They're correcting various ways of correcting errors that you think there should
be in this scheme of just the heading bonds together.
Now,
energy to terms determines what can happen.
Things always move toward equilibrium,
right?
So,
so if the ratio of two things is something with equilibrium ratio is different,
that ratio will always move toward that,
uh,
toward the equilibrium if it's in isolation.
But there's another equally important thing is how fast will it go there.
And that as we've seen before is to can be approximated as 10 to the 13th per
second times.
Uh,
this same kind of factor related to the barrier.
Now both of these things suggest that have being low in energy is good,
right?
Your favorite things that are low in energy,
but you might ask why.
That's not what people say about money.
They don't say the less money you have,
the better,
right?
Why?
The less energy the better.
This is a really interesting case and it has to do with statistics and
especially at Yale,
we should talk about this because in 19 two,
when Yale celebrated its bicentennial,
they've published a number of books showing off the scholarship of Yale.
Uh,
as you can see here,
and the most important of those books by about 500 miles was this one elementary
principals in statistical mechanics and the rational foundation of
thermodynamics by j Willard Gibbs.
So it's statistical mechanics.
It's trying to understand the behavior of chemical substances on the basis of
statistics.
Now when you do this,
you get exponents.
And the Organization of our presentation here is going to have to do with three
different ways in which statistics enters in to exponents for purposes of doing
equilibrium.
So there's the Boltzmann factor,
that's what we've been talking about,
the 10 to the three fourths Delta h that's called the Boltzmann factor.
It includes the Boltzmann constant.
Then there are things that have to do with entropy,
which is often seems to be a very confusing topic.
And finally there's a thing called the law of mass action.
And all of these things have exponents in them.
And if you understand how the exponent behave,
you understand what's going on.
So let's look first at the Boltzmann factor.
So here's Ludvig Boltzmann who committed suicide in 19 six.
And this is important paper on the relationship between the second law of
thermodynamics and probability calculations.
So statistics regarding the laws of thermal equilibrium in 1877.
Uh,
and his key equation is s equals k log w.
So log relates to an exponential and we'll see why that is.
And here's his tombstone in the cemetery in Vienna.
And you'll notice up at the top there as equals k log w.
Okay,
so what Boltzmann considered was the implication of random distribution of
energy.
Suppose you have a certain amount of energy in a system but it's distributed at
random,
right?
So it's purely statistically then how should it be distributed,
how much energy should any particular molecule have is the question.
And we can visualize this in a simple case,
which is very like what he did except he did it analytically and in a much
bigger system,
but just using four containers which are like molecules and each one can have a
certain amount of energy in it and we'll consider the energy to be,
to come in bits.
He used that idea that there were bits of energy to be distributed among
molecules or degrees of freedom within molecules.
Uh,
he didn't think that energy came in bits,
but it made it possible to do the statistics.
And then he just took the limit.
When these bits get very,
very,
very small so that it becomes like a continuum of stuff,
like a whole sand of,
of energy bits.
But anyhow,
let's just count up and how many different ways there are of putting three
different bits of energy are actually not different.
They're all the same,
but three bits of energy into the red container.
Okay?
So if you,
how many complexions?
That's what any particular arrangement he called a complexion.
How many different complexions have a certain number of bits in the first
container?
Well,
suppose you put all three of those energy bits into the first container.
How many different ways are there of doing that?
Just one.
Okay,
but suppose you put only two into the first container.
Now how many different ways are there of arranging it so that there are two in
the first container,
how many different ways there are?
Three.
One,
two,
three.
So there'll be three ways of putting two bits in the first container.
How many of putting one in the first container while we put one there?
There's one,
two,
three,
four,
five,
six ways of doing it.
Okay,
so there's six ways of putting one in there.
And how many of putting none at all in there.
One,
two,
three,
four,
five,
six,
seven,
eight,
nine,
10.
Okay,
so there are 10 ways of doing that.
So let's make a graph and see how many ways,
what's the probability that you'll have a certain number of bits of energy in
the first container?
Okay,
it looks like that 10,
six,
three one.
And what does that curve look like?
If you made a plot of that,
what type of curve does it look like?
Is it a straight line?
Anybody got a name for it or something that looks a little bit like that?
It's exponential decay.
Now,
it's not truly exponential in this case of three bits among four containers,
but if you do 30 bits among 20 containers,
then it looks like that.
And there is an exponential,
right?
So what Boltzmann was able to do to show mathematically was that the limits when
you have very many very small energy bits is truly an exponential.
So the probability of having a certain amount of energy in a degree of freedom
is exponential.
E to the minus whatever that energy is divided by Katie.
So Boltzmann showed that that was the limit for lots of infinite testable energy
bits.
And the idea behind it is quite clear if all the complexions for a given total
are equally likely,
and that's what he assumes.
It's random.
They can be any place they want to be.
Then shifting energy into any one degree of freedom of one molecule is
disfavored.
Because when you put more in one molecule,
there are fewer ways to distribute the rest among the others.
So there'll be fewer ways.
The more you put in this one is that clear cause that's really the key concept.
The more bits of energy you put in this one,
the fewer different ways there are of permuting what's left among the others.
Right.
And it's exponential,
right?
So if you have fewer ways among the others,
then it's less likely,
right?
So it turns out that if you do this,
the average energy is one half k t in this degree of freedom,
which is to say that k the Boltzmann constant relates temperature to average
energy,
which is to say that temperature is average energy temperature and average
energy at equilibrium are the same thing.
Okay?
For each degree of freedom you could.
But what,
what did we mean by these little buckets into which we could put energy?
We've met a way of putting energy into the molecule,
like stretching this bond or stretching this bond or bending some bonds or
torsion or something like that.
Now it true,
truly,
you know,
we deal with quantum states,
so you've put energy into different quantum states.
You count up the quantum states to see how likely things are.
Okay.
So that's where the Boltzmann factor is that exponential that he to the
exponential,
uh,
three fourths Delta h comes just because that's what you expect.
If you randomly distribute things,
it'll come out that way.
Now how about the entropy factor?
And this one is fun.
Uh,
Fineman in his wonderful lectures on physics
says it is the change from an ordered arrangement to a disordered arrangement,
which is the source of irreversibility.
Have you heard this?
Said that that entropy is disorder and that you increase Andrew entropy in order
to increase this order.
Okay?
So that's what fine.
But let's say the change from an ordered arrangement do a disordered
arrangement.
Okay.
Now here are two arrangements of the same number of dots,
which one is more ordered left or right.
Okay.
You know,
I'm setting you up,
right?
So your but I know what you would have voted for,
So I'm not going to ask you to vote.
Okay.
But look up the one on the right from a different point of view.
So what do you conclude?
Which one is more ordered?
The one on the right is just as ordered as the one on the left,
but we didn't perceive the order.
Okay.
And that's like constellations,
you know,
the shepherds lay out and saw bears and dragons and things in the sky.
Right.
And thought they were ordered.
Okay.
Now disorder reversibility and COO at flow.
Now I was,
I brought in the experiment to do here and it's,
but I'm not really sure it would work.
So what I'm gonna do,
cause I didn't practice it before I came,
I've done it before,
but I didn't practice it today on my pipette broken.
I had to get a new one made before class.
So if you want to see that come after class and we'll try the actual experiment.
But I'm going to show you a movie of it instead
here.
So this is the same thing here.
What it is is that,
well you'll see in the movie,
I'll just start it up.
Okay.
So it's a,
a glass that goes up inside a glass cylinder.
So there's like a donut inside,
right?
So I'm got to have been a poor kero syrup in there.
I brought the care of Syrup with me to show you.
So it's in that annulus between the rod and the cylinder.
Okay.
And now
I'm going to take some yellow dye and put a strip of it on.
First I'm going to market so I can tell I'm going to rotate that outside
cylinder.
So you can see that it's rotating and I'm putting a strip of yellow dye between
the rod and the cylinder.
Everybody see what I'm doing and then I'm going to stir it up.
And the way I'm going to stir it is by rotating the outside cylinder.
Okay.
So we'll zoom in and you'll see the watch not very well,
but to show that I'm not just running the movie backward or anything.
Okay.
Now I start rotating the downsides.
There's one rotation,
two rotations,
three rotations.
So now it's all mixed up.
And now watch,
I'm on rotating.
Yeah.
And it comes back.
So if you want to see that happen,
we'll try it after class here.
So you unmixed things that doesn't sound like entropy is working.
Right.
Okay.
No,
here's,
here's the way it actually happened.
So there was the syrup between the rod and the cylinder looked down from the top
and we put a strip of ink in between and then started rotating.
And as we rotated,
the ink spread out like this.
Right?
Cause the outer part moved and the inner part didn't move where it was in
contact with the Rod.
So after I'd done three rotations that looked like that,
it wasn't really evenly mixed up.
It's just that when we looked at it that looked like it was mixed up.
Right when we looked through it and now when we unrolled state it the whole
thing,
nothing diffused and molecules didn't move at random.
They just got spread out that way,
but in a particular way so it came back again.
Okay.
So the rotated state only seemed to be disordered.
So that's the basis of the trick.
Right.
But that raises a very fundamental question.
Yeah.
If disorder is in the mind of the beholder in this case or in the case of that
dinosaur connect the dots,
if disorder is in the mind of the beholder,
how can it beige or a fundamental property like entropy if it depends on who's
looking at it to say whether it's disordered or not.
Right.
In fact,
a disordered arrangement is an oxymoron because arrangement is and disordered is
not arrangement.
Right.
So how can you have a disordered arrangement?
If the shepherd sees a dragon.
Okay.
The situation favored at equilibrium
by entropy is one where particles have diffused every witch away,
not into a,
into a coiled up piece of paper,
like the yellow thing or not into it,
into a dinosaur.
The every witch away.
The key word is every,
that's what statistical about it.
A disordered arrangement is a code word for a collection of random distributions
whose individual structures are not obvious.
So if the thing looks like a,
you know,
a regular lattice like that,
I say a,
that's irregular lattice.
But if it looks like this,
I don't say it's,
it's exactly that.
I say it's disordered by which I mean I can't tell the difference between that
one and this one or this one or this one.
Right?
So there are a whole bunch of those arrangements that I count together.
When I say disorder,
it's a collective word.
So if all of them were equally likely,
it's much more likely to have disordered many,
many,
many arrangements than the particular ordered ones that we're thinking about,
even if they're all equally likely.
So that's the idea.
It is favored at equilibrium because it includes so many individual
distributions.
So entropy is actually counting in disguise.
You count all these different arrangements are all the different quantum levels
and the more you have under a certain name,
the higher the entropy associated with that name is.
So for example,
a very common value of the entropy difference between two things is 1.377
entropy units.
That seems a weird number right now.
1.377 happens to be our times the natural log of two.
Now consider the difference in entropy between Gauche and anti-beauty.
Okay,
so the equilibrium constant is e to the minus Delta g over our tea.
Do you remember what g is?
That's the Gibbs free energy,
which includes both heat,
both the kinds of things,
bond energy that we've been talking about and entropy is included in there too.
So we can split it apart into the part that has to do with heat that are
enthalpy,
the Delta h between the two things,
Goshen,
Auntie and t delta s the part that has to do with atrophy.
I suspect you've seen this.
G equals h plus ts before h minus t us before.
But let's just split it apart.
Since they're in the exponent,
we could multiply two things together.
So we have the first part,
the one we've been dealing with,
three fourths Delta H,
right?
And then we have the red part that has to do with entropy,
but you can simplify that.
How can you simplify the part that has to do with entropy at right off the bat?
Cancel the teas.
Okay,
so it's actually delta s over are now suppose that the value of Delta s is our
logged to,
which I said was a very common entropy difference.
Right now you can simplify it further.
Can you see how to simplify it further
for that particular interview difference?
Well obviously the RS cancel and what's he raised to the power of log to too.
So actually what that is is our three fourths Delta h times too.
So when you see 1.377 entropy units,
that's somebody who likes math telling you that there's a factor of two
involved.
That sounds more reasonable.
Right?
To,
why should there be a factor of two that favors Gauche over auntie butane?
Yeah,
there are twice as many goshes is there our aunties?
Cause it could be right handed or left handed goes.
So you'll see what a,
what a crop to this is to see that the entry to say that the attribute
difference between Goshen anti-beauty it is 1.377 entropy units.
It's just that there are twice as many of one of the other,
right.
So that the fact that Delta s occurs in an exponent is just a complicated way of
telling you that there's a statistical factor.
You have to count how many of these things there are.
Okay.
Because you have two Gauche butanes.
So the conclusion that it just means a factor of two and then that the
equilibrium constant depends on temperature because of Delta Age,
not because of Delta s often people think that because the free energy is,
is,
is uh,
h and t s that therefore the entropy thing is changing as t changes.
But in fact that's not true because you divide by t to get anything out of it.
Again.
Right.
So what really changes with temperature is the contribution due to Delta h.
So sometimes that's just used to obscure what is fundamentally very simple.
Okay,
we're gonna stop here and just so everybody's on the same page.
I will have the final lecture on Wednesday,
but then I'll be here at class time on Friday too,
and we can have a discussion then to review for the exam.
And I'm willing to have another one.
I forget.
When did I say on a Monday night.
Now,
do people are,
they're not exams at night,
are there?
Or are,
does anybody have a,
is Monday night?
Okay.
To have the review.
It's probably the best time to have it.
So you have a full day after that before that you say it.
So I'll get a room for,
for next Monday night,
a week from tonight for a review session.
Also,
I'll be here on Friday at lecture time.
So we'll see if anybody wants to see this experiment.
We'll do it.